hey guys it's Amanda Cerny and I'm here
with Brent Rivera who happens to have a
lot of questions about my first question
I don't know I've heard rumors but do
girls poop of course not
so they don't know but if they did it'd
be fine oh yeah
my next question uh do you want us to
fight a guy who is up in your face
uh I think if a guy is stepping up to a
girl she would want her guy to step in
front of her and kind of protect her
that way but not necessarily fight him
unless he throws a punch of the guy then
you know go for it okay next is out what
in your handbags Oh like what's in her
purse but I think every girl's different
but we all usually have five different
things of lip gloss um money credit
cards hair ties face spray like a face
mist little comb for my hair sometimes
odd like Advil or something just get
somebody needs it cuz I don't take it I
would carry around like a bunch of like
cool toys maybe some candy and we have
tampons stuff in there Oh do girls like
like dick pics Oh
I mean some girls might like it but I
think most are the they're not that
pretty
no I don't think it's I don't know just
don't your menstrual cycles really
attract bears yes
oh and sharks what about pandas no not
banished I love pandas
wait why are you upset pandas are
attracted to menstrual cycles are you
seriously expecting an honest response
to does this make me look fat
well how would you answer it is but this
make me look fat no but and I feel like
that was a lie because this shirt kind
of does like it's a way to expect people
not as expecting no I was not expecting
an honest response to that it's
appreciated when they do tell you the
truth but you're better off just saying
no because that's what we want to hear
can you take charge of the relationship
can I get okay this one's a good one are
all girls bisexual I think a lot of
girls are five curious so meaning that
if they see a girl like a hot girl what
they might imagine okay like what it's
like to make out with that girl I don't
know like this is like all normal things
I think I think that there's a sigma
scent for like bisexual girls making out
and it being super hot guys getting
turned on like by it so right because
that's the thing right but I don't think
every girl is bisexual but I think
girls are vicarious saying okay do girls
watch porn
um I think Oh some girls do probably a
lot of girls do but I think girls are
more into storyline like fifty Shades of
Grey
I mean that's like a woman's porn I
think and then you guys okay our girls
offended when you check out their boobs
or butt a lot of girls wear clothing
that enhance those certain parts of
their body that they like so some show
their cleavage some show their but then
I think if guys are discreet about it
it's fine check them out it depends on
the situation too if you're having a
one-on-one conversation here - staring
at the girls think they're going to get
pissed off because I kind of want you to
connect with them and not with their
chest do girls check out guys goods -
like would you check okay yeah girls
check guys out sometimes not all the
time not as much as guys do but if
you're wearing like I don't know tight
shorts I don't know why you would be
wearing tight you wear tight shirts all
the time okay well why do girls go to
the bathroom in groups because they like
to gossip in there so that's one thing
so they're probably talking about you
they just feel protected when they're
with other people because we're kind of
like trained but you know be cautious or
we need to borrow somebody's like lip
gloss or borrow tampon and don't want to
exchange it at the table so okay what is
it like to be on your period because
I've never been on you know no I guess
what happened soon or Nick I will
probably in a couple years
it sucks uh happens once the month
Glasser about a week most girls do have
some mood swings
so we'll get very like angry really
quickly may start yelling at you it's
also a lot of cramps so the fetal
position is like a great thing to thing
to do
cravings I love chocolate yeah yeah we
just get fatter and angrier get in my
belly
okay actual cycle why do girls spend so
much money and time on makeup
how long does it take to put on makeup
for you it depends if I'm getting my
makeup done for a shoot or something
that might take like 30 to 45 minutes if
I'm doing it myself it might take five
to 15 wormboy
how often do girls like crap talk about
their friends I think girls usually
gossip but I mean the ones that do talk
[ __ ] about their friends for no reason
at all behind their back I think those
are just like people do you ever call
guys [ __ ] and it's light as somebody
who sleeps with multiple people like a
lot of people it's very promiscuous
right that's the definition is I don't
know I think it's just such a horrible
word in general that nobody should even
ever call anybody that's yeah just don't
be mean would you do you like chesty on
a guy I just wanted to know just for
future reference that with or without
why so angry by the toilet seat bingo ah
left the toilet seat up well my mom
always like make sure your dad puts the
toilet seat down so it was like built-in
to me my sister yells me too it should
be down for when the woman walks in
there
and it's already ready for us Oh
it's like opening the door put the
toilet seat down how common are push-up
bras think every girl has a push-up bra
not like the witchcraft bras got my are
extremely padded and put your boobs up
to here and then when they take it off
it's just like nothing why didn't women
continue to give subtle hints after
thousands of years of it never working
because we know we can't make you want
to do something so for me what I like
they're little hints at you so maybe in
your brain and like simon and trigger
something so were you getting up doing
that really well my god he didn't even
have to tell him is every girl born with
amazing penmanship do you want to see me
write SunZia I do all right my name okay
that's the horrible no that is not
that's worth I was like a third-grader
handwriting no really bad no way
seriously looks like it's like a fog on
Microsoft Word no it's crazy no one
looks at you no I'm serious
just let me go see my n ready yeah all
right well mine's pretty bad business is
worse I think we were slightly better
than men again
naturally you didn't drink your team
this that's what the ladies do very much
to carry to play with you I think so I
saw it in my piece if you wanna be fancy
hold your pinky up like this so I just
answered a bunch of questions that all
men in the world want to know they sit
right here and if you want to follow him
you can just click right here right here
on this man and you can go to his
channel and subscribe you can also click
down in the link below to find him so
thanks for watching bye
[Music]